en pleine guerre iran irak en 1988 dans
le détroit d'ormuz
un croiseur américain de vincennes à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de là un
airbus de la compagnie iran air d'école
de bandar abbas pour rejoindre dubaï
il y à 290 personnes à bord le navire de
guerre va tirer deux missiles l'avion
explose en vol
les autorités iraniennes ont promis de
se venger se venger de ce que le
pentagone a qualifié d' erreur d' erreur
tragique accompli au nom de la légitime
défense
l'armée assure avoir confondu l'airbus
avec un chasseur f 14
jamais les états unis n'ont présenté
d'excusés officielles
quelques années auparavant en pleine
guerre froide
un avion de la korean airlines fait la
liaison entre l'alaska et séoul
mais il dévie de sa trajectoire
survolent l'espace soviétique
un chasseur le prend pour cible échange
avec sa base base tirer pilote feu c'est
cette conversation qui a mené les états
unis a accusé ouvertement l'urss d'être
à l'origine de la catastrophe qui a fait
260 morts dont une dizaine de canadiens
mais l'erreur dans ce cas ce n'est pas
le tir de missile c'est la trajectoire
de l'avion
il y a évidemment les 298 victimes
collatérales qui avaient pris place à
bord du vol m h 17 en 2014 l'avion de la
malaysian airlines est abattu au dessus
de l'ukraine l'enquète établira qu'un
missiles de fabrication russe a explosé
à un mètre de la cabine l'armée
ukrainienne et la russie se rejettent
encore la responsabilité et puis il faut
rappeler les spéculations en 1996 quand
le vol lui sembla twh se disloque au
large de long island
plus de 24 heures après le drame la
question demeure le vent lui sans de
l'athée w at il été victime d'un
accident ou d'un attentat
une photo va même circuler son s'est
montré un missile dans le ciel new
yorkais
il faudra attendre quatre ans pour que
la lumière soit faite
c'est le réservoir central de l'appareil
qui aurait provoqué l'explosion restent
à établir avec certitude la séquence qui
a abouti à cette main
ce boeing qui a explosé ce mercredi
après son décollage
si mathieu prost radio-canada à montréal